so the challenges voters team faces are
not exclusive to want exclusive
capturing data from different sources
performing various kinds of analysis for
different clients ensuring that the data
analyst is accurate timely and useful
this is common challenge across the
companies right GCP offers many
solutions that can help you tango you
know tame this problem and get the right
set of insights for your business so
let's dive in when people say Google
first instinct is to think of search and
with our original mission to organize
the world's information and make it
universally accessible Google had to
solve many technical project project
problems to be able to reach you know to
build a service that can serve billions
of people many of these technical
challenges were necessary for search but
there are actually general-purpose big
data challenges so we had to solve
storage problem we have a different
types of data and we need the different
storage solutions for them file systems
databases key value stores etc we needed
to process this data and some of this
data needed to be processed as a batch
or as a streaming right like they have
different trade-offs and finally we need
to figure out how to serve our service
right how can we deploy an update
running service with no downtime so over
the time our infrastructure involved and
our business involved so now we have
like I think eight services that have a
daily reach more than a billion users
and with this growth our technical
infrastructure evolved as well and we
are now able to support very different
use cases yet all of these use cases
still share the same infrastructure
hardware networking and and software
stack in the last 15 years we've
published about our infrastructure and
the tools we've built starting with GFS
and MapReduce papers BigTable Dremel all
the way to data flow in tensor flow in
the last few years we've actively
changed our Google infrastructure but
also influenced the industry
now many of these products have evolved
into cloud offerings and unlocking this
infrastructure to our external customers
we have a variety of products in compute
storage and databases space big data and
machine learning and in a next few
slides I'll highlight the few that are
relevant to routers case so
micro-services as you heard give you
flexibility to solve one problem at a
time they're easier to develop test and
deploy that makes some popular choice
however maintaining micro services is
not a trivial job right you need to be
able to scale them upgrade them without
downtime and figure out where things go
wrong so this is where Google container
engine comes to play container engine
provides a fully managed container
solution and allows you to deploy your
the conch containerized workflows so we
get a powerful cluster manager and
orchestration system that is built on
top of open source kubernetes it's a
prize it has a private container
registry so you have your own micro
services well-defined and hidden
convenient and powerful declarative API
for resource specification and because
it's built on kubernetes which is open
source and there are many other partners
and companies out there who are using
this it actually allows you to combine
both public client a cloud and
on-premise solutions so using something
like container engine and kubernetes you
can have a hybrid cloud ok the data
warehousing is a huge part of every
business right and SQL is the yeah
interface of choice to this data sets in
a Google cloud platform if you have a
data sets of up to 10 but if I 10
terabytes you can use Google Cloud SQL
with it you get a fully managed and
reliable scale service building Postgres
or MySQL that comes with automatic
failover and optionally high
availability mode you do not have to
upgrade your database you do not have to
monitor it all the time right
like we ensure that nothing happens to
our machine and the things just run it's
a performance and scaleable up to 10
terabytes to 25,000 yups and it comes
with automatic encryption and you have a
full control over firewall settings and
you can protect your access to the
database being MySQL and Postgres it has
a strong partner ecosystem her if your
data set grows to more than 10 terabytes
you still you and you still want to use
SQL we do have solution for that and
it's a Google Cloud bigquery beaker is
the fully managed low-cost surveillance
data warehouse you never see the
machines you just go to the website and
enter your queries right it has a
exposes SQL interface it has a seamless
scalability from gigabytes to petabytes
and it's secure and reliable again
automatic encryption automatic
replication all of this happens behind
the curtains you don't see it you just
use the service however even with
bigquery scale in performance there are
problems that require sort of
guaranteeing low latency and consistent
throughput which is hard to guarantee
with a SQL service right so for this
case is we have a Google called BigTable
this is a knows SQL big data database
that powers many of the products you
probably use search analytics Maps Gmail
it's behind all of that it's again fully
managed no SQL database you don't get to
see the machines again in for all
practical purposes it has a better scale
scalability with a very low latency and
it can grow the throughput as needed the
interesting thing with BigTable is
depending on your access patterns it
learns and adjust to them so over the
time you're serving becomes more
efficient
so we looked at some of the storage
solutions now you have this data you
want to process it many of you are
coming from none from existing
frameworks that may have been built on
open source tools like Apache Hadoop or
spark right we want you to be able to
reuse these tools in your applications
so we have a Google Cloud data product
offering and this is stateless cloud and
the beta proc gives you stateless
clusters that can spin up in the seconds
up to a minute and can read and write
the data to various sources like GCS
BigTable bigquery with an HDFS and HBase
compatible connectors it also provides
convenient API for management of both
clusters and jobs
so with data Frank you can choose
whether you want to run your data per
cluster as a long living cluster with
HDFS and everything in it on it like you
did on premise or another cloud provider
or you can take a you know benefits of a
low latency that we have for startup
starting clusters and run a job per
cluster and just bring down the cluster
when your job is done
so Peter Brook is great but we learned a
few things in data processing in Google
so petabyte scale processing engine
Google Way is our cloud dataflow many of
the data for took many of the internal
learnings and turned them into data data
processing solution that scales have
both for batch and streaming workloads
it is fully managed and now - configured
you can start data for jobs but not
specifying it much anything much than
code and it comes with a it provides
unified batch and streaming processing
model so you write your data
transformations once and depending on
input source and output source that you
use we have a streaming pipeline or we
have a batch pipeline so if you're
consuming pub/sub while i you are having
streaming if you're consuming GCS you're
reading the batch right and we open
source the dataflow SDK and turned it
into Apache beam project in the last
year so we scale to petabytes of data
millions of QPS automatically and we
invested a lot of time in high quality
integrations with GCP
oops Google called platinum showing
seamless integration of these powerful
tools you can use any one of them and be
perfectly happy but real power of the
platform comes from using them together
and providing comprehensive solution
that's well integrated with monitoring
debugging alerting and all these other
things and this is where GCP excels so
with us let's go back to business
intelligence gifts so we ended with this
slide so it's a quick recap before we
want to go I'm gonna start with our
original architecture like I encountered
it in 2013 when I started and how it
still lives so we have a monolithic
about net application on top of a SQL
cluster and for reporting purposes we
copy the data every night to a separate
reporting database so that the analysts
don't bring down production that's
pretty obvious most of the analysis
happens in Excel using queries that they
write directly on the database and then
me and Alex my tech lead came in and we
started to push most of our really large
data sets into the clouds into bigquery
mostly this is email we sent about two
million emails per day and we have about
five rows of data potentially per email
so that's quite a lot of rows click
tracking is also up to 20 million rows
on a single day
SQL couldn't manage that but bigquery
does it fine
we also copy production data through
cloud storage into bigquery so that our
analysts can can enrich the data that
they get from these streams with the
data from production of course with one
day of delay
we've adopted tableau as the new tool to
analyze data as a replacement to excel
and it's bringing the data that we have
in in in SQL and in bigquery to pretty
much everyone in the company through
very nice looking dashboards so that's
what so we're already quite data-driven
lastly personalization is also a part of
my team it's what our data scientists do
and they run it in PI spark on top of
cloud data program so we are using this
stateless version of what the other nine
explain we provision we spin up a server
at night we do our calculations which
import data from cloud storage and
bigquery and the results go back into
cloud storage and then we copy it out
back over to production this is a big
pain point because we generate a lot of
data out of out of spark this can be
really millions of rows and the copying
takes quite a long time so this is a
really big pain point do the new
architecture then because that's what
why you're here for the new architecture
will be angular front-ends on top of
dope net core micro services running in
containerized linux environment in
kubernetes all of them have their own
MongoDB database so no SQL or in some
cases cloud SQL I'm not going to go into
much detail about cuban areas and
containers because i'm like the BI guy
but if you have any questions feel free
to to come up after the show this is a
very basic back of the screen like we
have it today I hope you can read it I'm
not sure but what this shows is for our
employees inside one of those deals that
we have all of the products their name
price stock information how many orders
we've had so far how many views we had
so that they can have some kind of an
indication of conversion and use this to
intervene in live sales now to make this
screen in our new environment we're
gonna do you I will have to contact four
different micro services and bigquery
it's gonna be horribly complicated so my
team said look we'll just provide you
with a micro service which gives all of
that data as a single JSON payload and
we'll figure out where to get the data
and how to merge it
so how do we get the data microservices
obviously they talk to each other they
use direct endpoint calls but also as
synchronous events so let's say you have
a member service a new member registers
it sent an event and some kind of utter
service which is responsible for sending
out our welcome mail says hey new member
I'm gonna send a mail without needing a
direct call now we require all of our
micro services to send out events for
the entities that they manage internally
being it a product an article a member
an order and each time these things get
created or modified we send events over
cloud pub/sub and all of those events
are red bar data flow and store it into
cloud BigTable so that my team's bi
environment has a perfect copy of what
is happening in the micro services how
we do that in practice we use Google
protocol buffers which is a very nice
technology for making these kinds of
events so you define them as a schema
and from that schema you generate the
serialization code in most common
programming languages and they end up
being serialized in very small very
efficient binary files which go over the
pub sub bus are read by our streaming
data flow and we just store them in
BigTable as binary so no
decentralization happens in this flow
it's actually a very simple flow
BigTable is really nice because as
Jelena said you can reach very high
throughput very low latency it which is
what we need because we're gonna be
firing a lot of events and a nice
feature as well is that when you write a
cell into bigquery it's time-stamped and
every older version of that cell is kept
so we not only have a copy of our marker
service environment but we also know the
entire history of everything that ever
that that ever happened so all of the
email address changes that users did
changes to orders modifications to
addresses all of those things are kept
we can roll things back and we can
replay history if we want
how do we bring the data back BigTable
is not for reporting that's a key value
store so we use our own micro-services
written in Python or Google go to read
the data out of BigTable and serve it to
back-office screens other micro services
where needed the really large data
streams as before go straight into
betrayal
it doesn't make sense to fire those into
BigTable so we've got our data in
MongoDB cloud SQL we've got our external
data in bigquery what we want in the end
is analyze data in production data so
the production data is to do things like
that back off a screen that I showed you
and analyst data is to raw entity data
all of our users all of our orders all
of our returns but also that
pre-processed data that we were talking
about so the turnover we did on a sale
last year and unique visitors we had so
how do we do that how do we use the the
intermediate technologies like pub/sub
data flow and BigTable to get there well
it depends a bit on the scenario but we
see like for patterns or strategies that
we use in combination to get there so
one of them I have to real time
strategies into batch mode strategies
the first real-time strategy is to read
from different pops ups at the same time
combine the data in data flow and bring
that to BigTable an example we get new
users in every day
but our analysts don't just want to know
how many new users we had they also
don't know where do they come from and
what kind of divides it they used the
members service will send us an event
about a new user but that doesn't
contain that information that they need
from the click stream which is another
pub/sub stream so we read both we
combine the data and we store that final
output in BigTable we need to do it like
that because when we're reading the
click stream we can't assume that the
member entity will already be in
BigTable another strategy is to read
data from pub/sub process it in cloud
dataflow and load side information from
BigTable for example when you want to
calculate the unique visitors per
country or clickstream tells us that who
is clicking where but it doesn't tell us
what the country of that user is so we
ask BigTable to tell us the country
we generate our KPI and we store it in
BigTable so that's the second strategy
that I will demonstrate at the end if I
have enough time that screen that we
talked about that back of the screen
will actually already be a combination
of both strategies to make that possible
then batch mode here we will read data
mostly from from bigquery also from
BigTable we'd combine it calculated in
cloud dataflow and the end result goes
black in back into cloud BigTable if we
do a lot of processing for various kinds
of reports things that people often eat
that the analysts need pre-calculated
that will be mostly this example for
example an email campaign report that's
a lot of email click data that comes
from bigquery it's enriched because this
data is pretty bare that email tracking
data and reached with memory information
and the results go to into BigTable and
as before this the data science stuff
goes into stateless cloud data proc but
instead of reading from SQL as we do
today we read from cloud BigTable and
the results also go back to cloud
BigTable so that we can very fastly
provision this data into production
without needing to copy it over again to
an SQL server as we did before where the
data ends up in the end
depends on who needs it if we need it in
the back office or in production we
serve it through a micro service and the
data resides in BigTable if our analysts
need it we create a data set in BigTable
and depending on the frequency required
hourly daily weekly we use a data flow
to stream this data into bigquery or
cloud SQL well both actually so that
people can join the stuff in in bigquery
with these huge data sets because the
really large data sets like our click
stream and email stream we will just
enrich them with BigTable data and story
result in bigquery as really large
denormalized data sets
what if things go wrong and they do and
they will we back up all of our events
so all of the events are also read from
pops up by a dedicated backup streaming
data flow which stores all of them again
as binary into bigquery there's an
additional batch job which copies it to
cold storage just in case somebody wants
to delete the table in between restoring
happens by using the same data flows
streaming or batch doesn't matter the
streaming can be run as batch two and we
change the input from originally pops up
to bigquery which contains exactly the
same binary protocol different files and
we store the corrected information again
in cloud thick table
so now for the demo live time yes we
have time so this is a very simple data
flow that I've built specifically for
showing it here to demonstrate a little
bit of what we are doing so it's on our
actual production data today because all
of what you I've been explaining to you
it's not done yet we're building it but
we've of course tested a lot of these
things conceptually so I'm gonna write
our current production data as event
sources over cloud pub/sub I'm gonna
count them but from the click stream I
don't know the country so I'm gonna get
the country from BigTable and I'm gonna
store the result as a time series again
in cloud BigTable and I will use a
simple nodejs bare-bones web service to
show that on a browser screen so let's
have a look
then I switch to the computer so when
you load your data flow in data flow in
the interface or the runner online you
get a very nice overview in books of
what your pipeline is actually doing so
it starts with reading from pub/sub it's
when doing it in this case in one minute
windows we do some internal conversion
to a closet we 10news in java we filter
it and then we count the views and
within that we first get that country
from BigTable and then we count the
actual views that gets converted into a
mutation which is then finally committed
to BigTable and the interface is really
nice you can see how many workers are
doing the job and you actually read that
yes one you can check logs look for
exceptions if anything is going wrong
it's really nice interface now pops up I
can't show you much about that but what
I can show you is tag driver which shows
us how many events are coming in so
currently we have a good 100 events per
second going through while going through
the pub subchannel if I show you that
per day you see the typical morning and
even in big deaths that our website has
so we're seeing events now what kind of
events are those this is our website
let's say I'm interested in shoes
I'm actually doing this over a phone
because the Wi-Fi wouldn't cooperate so
bear with me so I'm gonna show your
products for 20 micro now we've bigquery
they look like this I'm gonna refresh
this that beaker is really nice for
these very deep tables so this is a
table of probably a good 10 million rows
now it has some set up time in the
beginning because your Aquarian gets
dispatched over X amount of machines and
then the results come back so it takes a
few seconds but then it goes very
quickly so you see here I have a product
fuse our light updated I've devised
identify our session ID in the first
this is that user identifier that we'll
be using and we also store some
additional unstructured data in jason-2
mostly to optimize things like
recommender engines in cities so finally
what is this gonna look like BigTable I
can't show you much of BigTable but this
is how it looks if you if you talk to it
using a command-line interface so I'm
gonna get to the last few events and
here you see my time series oh can you
either here you see my time series so
you see the events the page views for
Belgium Luxembourg and Netherlands being
written per minute and with the time
stamp so you see when the the data was
being written into BigTable so this is
how it looks like so you see my one
minute time series that was generated by
dataflow and to show you the real real
timeless of the thing I've instructed
dataflow to update my latest we know
every few seconds so these are the
actual events coming on our website
right now it's not fake
and voila this gives you an idea of how
you can use cloud dataflow to use these
kinds of things so back to jana
okay thank you about er so to summarize
today we've seen an explorative event
exclusives business intelligence use
case but look at the GCP products that
make this use case easier to manage and
we also seen a pretty cool demo I'm
still baffled like that we're looking at
the production data like it's it's neat
we hope that you will recognize
similarities with with problems that
you're facing and the problems that the
routers team tried to solve and that
some of these will inspire you on how
you can combine the services we have to
provide a solution that works for you
and at that this point like we are very
happy to take any questions you may have
we ended up being a little bit faster
than we expected so lots of questions
and I have some stickers if anyone wants
okay
you want to repeat do you have on top of
the technical stack itself so do you
have these business scenarios or use
cases somehow capture in to say
templatized formats like certain
business cases or specific types of use
cases we we do have a couple of things
for this on a cloud google.com slash Big
Data they are templated like examples of
a different business use cases I think
we have six or nine I know there are
three Acoma but I don't know how many
rows we have all of them have a code in
github so you can actually see how the
code looks like and many of them are
integration between the different
products because it's like in a big
table of a big data space we also have a
ton of data sets that are available
through bigquery or on GCS that you can
use to sort of explore the ideas that
you have so yeah so there's some
documentation some of the examples there
we also offer some trainings for these
things and I believe if you're
interested in that I can find more
information I don't know it on top of my
head but we definitely continually build
this database of the sort of white
papers and examples and I think very
recently we had a like I think this week
or Friday last week we had a publication
by one of our SME subject matter experts
Raisa on the best practices when using
the big data tools and that will be
ongoing series so he published the first
part last week
so thanks for your presentation maybe a
question for a for Walter how do you
deal with a personally identifiable
information that comes from your website
in regards to the the nature of BigTable
which stores every record and also every
mutation of every record especially now
with gdpr coming coming coming up so my
question is very general how do you deal
with it it's a very good question and
we've thought about it a lot now what
what cloud platform really loud allows
you to do really well is it set
permissions on a technology level so
each service you can keep it away from
people you can use specific service
accounts so we don't want any analysts
talking to our BigTable we also don't
want any not even other developers
talking to our big table or other micro
services we we keep that inside our own
team and we get to say what we export to
the databases that allow them to
generate reporting because they can't
use BigTable they can only use cloud SQL
or a big tail or a big query so there we
can use separate tables so that's that's
a bit the idea that we're gonna use
we're gonna we're gonna pull all of the
information that's really personally
identifiable in different tables and
they would need to join it together
to know who it really is and only some
people like in customer care can do that
that it will be done in their back
office they will get the rights to do
that but most people will not be able to
because you don't need to know that
information to do most of your work
anyway is it kind of an also to your
question
okay
thanks again so is there
okay specify in in BigTable a type of
retention period so the gdpr specifies
that some type of data you will have to
delete in
in maybe two years or five years
depending on the type of data can you
set a retention period or he said is
that a thing you have to have to add a
little process in your flow to take care
of that so that's an excellent question
so do we have a capability to
automatically remove the data after a
certain period of time and I would have
to look up what a big table exactly sets
I know we do have these support for
these things for example in data flow
and we we have a services for this in
Google so you register and if the
information is deleted you have to yank
it out of your system so specifically
for BigTable I don't know but I can look
it up and but we definitely care and you
know about the data and we barely Relan
or we are very well aware of the data
policies so this is something we care
about we are currently working with with
consultants who are specialized in this
and even they don't know how it's gonna
be so it's gonna be with the EU cookie
law some big players are gonna make the
first move and the rest will kind of
standardize on that and it's also not
it's not that clear-cut you don't have
to delete the data they tell us you have
to anonymize it so you have to delete
someone's name and email address but you
can still keep views and orders and some
data you will even need to keep like an
invoice you will need to keep that
forever in your database which is also
personally identifiable information so
it's it's much more complicated than
that
for you
and the other questions yeah okay I so
my question is for water I was listening
to your presentation and I think it's
nice but what for me was missing was
that I want to believe that this journey
has not been all roses and if there has
been any hurdles that you've encountered
in this process that you want to share
that would be as an example for anybody
who wants to be on this migration Jenny
but I think one of the main hurdles if
you see what kind of evolution we we
went through is it's getting to grips
with the different breeds of technology
that Google has BigTable is really a
very different kind of database than an
SQL database and if you look at it it
says it it looks as if you simply can't
do much with BigTable you who read rows
you scan rows and you write them and
that's it but their schema design is
absolutely essential for what you want
to do so you need to spend more time
thinking about such things so and and
there's also a lot of yeah mistakes that
you make beginner mistakes the first
data flows that we wrote yeah that
didn't go over roses we needed to get to
grips with the technology so you need to
invest a lot of time in learning and and
I hope your company allows you to do
that because you will spend some time
yeah trying things out but presumably
it's worth it right okay there's a
question
while the thing for presentation how big
is your team which they thought is true
and built built the implementations the
complete IT department is between 40 and
50 people I don't know exactly and my
department is just seven people but I
think there were some key people in
there are our architects like Alex
lousier upfront it says it's his
brainchild that I'm presenting here so
we did a marvelous job so if you want to
congratulate him or ask a more in-depth
questions it's actually one of the only
Google development experts in Belgium or
the only one for cloud not anymore
and he works for us we're very happy
with that that helps a lot it does okay
thanks
question 4 router why and how did you
choose Google clouds what was the
decision tree very good question now as
you've seen we're not a big company
we're not a bank or another a big
retailer and when I came into the
company we were only like 90 people
where were three times that so it was a
twenty people IT team and and yeah two
guys taking care a little bit of bi so
we we had no time or resources to
compare 20 different providers
technologies and whatnot so the decision
was based on a few things one of them
was to be a very good relationship with
with Google because we are we were we
were top adwords client we've got people
with a lot of experience with google
technology like like alex but i think
one of the main reasons was that google
has these technologies that jelena has
been showing us things like bigquery I
mean three three three years ago we were
baffled by the power that thing has and
this-this-this pushed us over the edge
and and also the fact that everything
can be done in a managed way I mean you
can run redshift - you can run Kafka but
you still have to do a lot of management
of all the servers that run below these
things and we simply do not have the
resources to do that if we need to do
that ourselves it will take us two years
just to build the infrastructure so that
was one of the key reasons for us to do
it like this because with a very small
team between the really powerful stuff
any other questions
I'm sorry
can you use the mic thank you did you
make use of a Google partner or was it
completely your team that for this not
though for original architecture we did
kind of all the first steps into big
query three years ago we talked a little
bit to data toilet who's here and has a
booth and I think went in to Cloud Data
Platform because of us
so we had some chats training the
beginning to confirm some of the of the
big beds that we were taking but that's
about it
the rest is made in-house
okay okay well thank your own for coming
and you can grab this after this